on allume on continue dans le sexe et la
défonce
mais cette voie dans un milieu inattendu
le sikhisme voici willy meute
justement comment ça va ça va bien mais
on dit willie willie voûte vous êtes
belge en fait je suis belge faisant
quelques blessés légers
j'ai pas appris le français à la limite
académie française
oui j'ai appris le français dans la peur
de tomber à la latence est bon donc vous
êtes l'ancien soigneur de festina oui et
donc j'étais occupé de virac pendant des
années vous avez de girac et vous
publiez votre deuxième livre qui
s'appelle sexe mensonges et vélos petit
le petit léo c'est un roman merci
patrick boré c'est un roman qui sort
chez calmann-lévy donc en fait c'est un
roman mais c'est des faits réels sauf le
dernier chapitre vous le préciser alors
on apprend un truc extraordinaire ça
vous intéresser les filles c'est que
dans vélo il ya non seulement des
piquouse mais il ya des partouzes c'est
vrai c'est la réduit sa rivale savez
même tout le monde sait que les
cyclistes qui se défoncent puisqu'on
attend ce qu'on apprend dans la boue cas
c'est que non seulement ça se défonce
mais en plus ça baise à mort d'un sans
fond ce bravo alors c'est la vie d'un
jeune cycliste qu'à 23 ans qui s'appelle
arnaud crochet évidemment tout le monde
parle de vous parce que bientôt avoir
lieu à la rentrée le procès festina donc
avec vous et puis vire a été défoncée
comme il dit à l'issue de son plein gré
évident que ça vous a fait du mal c'est
trahison parce que vous dites c'est
celui que j'ai le plus aimé le plus aidé
ça m'a fait très très mal parce que
c'était un peu mon fils dit l'avenue
dans ce milieu un peu au hasard parce
que ce n'était pas un super à madaoui
alors j'ai fait beaucoup de choses pour
lui j'ai beaucoup aidé et je peux dire
que je suis pour un petit peu qu'est ce
qu'il est devenu
en parlant de visite il a et j quand je
me suis fait arrêter
donc j'ai pensé que c'était lui comme
ils l'avaient pas demandée relations
c'est lui qui va me sens vraiment ce
qu'elle vous a pas sorti
non non il vous a trahis et vous vite
d'ailleurs en parlant de richard
virenque vous dit il en a beaucoup dans
les jambes mais pas beaucoup dans la
tête et votre fils lui il a décroché le
poster de sa chambre il ya décroché lé
ton pays tu veux faire de l'irak
il a décroché et joue au foot et je vous
foutent pas des jouets